[Inaudible].
A loan from the United States government to the Eastman Kodak company,
the famous company that led the photography industry for decades to start
manufacturing, pharmaceutical ingredients to fight COVID-19.
This news alone was enough to cause the iconic American company to skyrocket on
the stock exchange in just two sessions between 27th and 29th of July,
2020 Kodak shares Rose by 2190%. Yep. That's what I said.
2190%.
The share price increased 23 fold in just two days on the stock market.
The price went from $2 and 62 cents at the close of trading on 27th of July to
$60 on the 29th. Of course, as you can see in this graph,
after reaching the $60 level, the action quickly corrected to the $8 level,
which was current at the time of preparing this video.
Even. So.
That means multiplying the average price of the last few months by almost four.
And that's kind of movement made us wonder what exactly has happened so that the
shares of this company went from $2 to $60 and finally $8.
It's just a few days. And from there spring more quick,
And it's because of this, the price of Kodak shares has increased four fold,
but despite this,
the current market value of this company is that about $600 million a far cry
from the more than $20 billion that Kodak reached in 1994. At that time,
the American photography giant represented 0.5% of the entire value of the SNP
500, which in today's terms would be equivalent to a bounce of $150 billion.
So.
What's happens to make Kodak collapse.
How did the company that led the global photography market for more than a
hundred years, lose more than 98% of its value and go bankrupt intimately.
[Inaudible].
Did you know that since then this company has tried at Slack with
cryptocurrencies or that even built its own nuclear reactor in secret? Well,
it's not. So.
This.
Video of the series that we're making in conjunction with value score,
we are going to tell you all the details about the fall of Kodak over the last
few decades. And it's surprising takeoff in the middle of the Corona.
Why was crisis by the way.
Is that linked to value schools website?
If you want to know more about this project.
Make it easy. George Eastman.
Kind of the Steve jobs of his time. And no,
I'm really not exaggerating in 1874 at the age of 24,
good old George bought his first camera,
which at that time was not exactly common. And in fact,
what happened is that when he used it for the first time during a vacation,
he didn't manage to take a single picture. In those days,
cameras were very different from the ones that we know they were much more
difficult to use. It. Wasn't just a matter of pushing a button.
You actually had to use individual glass plates for every single picture,
but you know what? This is precisely how the Kodak story begins.
Eastman didn't give up and hired a photographer to give him some private
lessons.
You could say that's when his love affair with the world of photography began 14
years later in 1888,
Eastman registered the Kodak trademark and obtained a patent for a new camera
that used film instead of blast plates, the era of film had the gun,
which was obviously much easier and faster to take pictures with. And in fact,
the same technology could be applied to me.
Movies. In fact.
From that moment on Kodak began to market its cameras,
using a slogan that reflected very well.
What would become the brand's philosophy? You press the button.
We do the rest.
Wasn't the only indicator,
the only distinguishing feature of the company Kodak's other major innovation
also had a lot to do with trade policy, but it was something very different.
You see when selling their cameras Kodak soon,
applied a bait and switch strategy equivalent to that of the razor companies
that is selling the camera at the lowest possible price and making money from
the sale of reels rolls of film, photographic paper, and other.
Applies.
They made the cameras accessible to the general public.
What was feeding a market with constant income. And that's not all after all,
this was a kind of business that was not so easy to get into making the film
roles was quite complex. It required a deep knowledge of chemistry,
especially when color photos became popular from the 1960s.
Onwards.
And so it was that by the mid 1970s,
Kodak had become by far the largest photo company in the world to give you an
idea in the United States, it controlled 90% of the market for roll film,
85% of the market for cameras.
And it was also a very important player in the medical imaging sector.
And not only that in the 1980s,
Kodak began to make a lot of corporate purchases to expand its business lines.
For example,
it took over IBM's medical diagnostics business and also acquired mass memory,
a company that manufactured the popular floppy disks in
1988,
it even launched a $5.1 billion cash takeover bid that's just over 11 billion
in today's money on the pharmaceutical company Sterling drug.
The idea was to take advantage of the photo companies.
Chemical know how to break into the promising world of pharmacy.
For Kodak shareholders.
The merger will accelerate our entry into the more than $110 billion global
pharmaceutical industry.
It will provide us with attractive long-term sales and profit potential Colby,
H Chandler, president and CEO of Kodak in 1988.
Of course, a few years later,
they had to sell this business for far less than they had acquired it for.
The fact is that in the early 1990s,
this company Kodak was a global Colossus employing more than
120,000 people. However, that was to be their last decade of success,
the fall over Colossus.
How is it possible that one of the largest multinationals in the United States,
a giant that had dominated the world market for more than a hundred years,
went from achieving its all time sales record in 2001 to going bankrupt just
10 years later and practically disappearing. Okay.
So many of you may be thinking, Josh, this is an easy question.
We all know the answer, technological change and the advent of digital.
Hammers. Well, yes.
And in a way, no,
I'll explain one of the biggest risks that an investor faces is a technological
disruption and a paradigm shift will soon overtake the business model of the
company in which they have invested their money.
And it's true that in a way that's exactly what happened with Kodak,
but looked at it from a different angle. It's not that simple.
What would you say if I told you that the first digital camera was born in their
laboratories as early as 1975,
that Kodak itself began marketing these cameras in the 1990s,
including the first professional digital camera in 1991, that's by 1993,
this company had already invested more than $5 billion in research on digital
technology that in 97, you could find headlines like this.
January 13th, 1997, how an outsider's version saved Kodak.
The remarkable turnaround that he has produced at Eastman Kodak,
George Fisher shows why the board chose him an outsider and late 1993 to run
this company, Forbes friends.
This is a much more interesting case than it might seem at first glance because
codex vol was not so much related to technological change as it was to the
company's management of its adaptation process and poor business strategy.
And you know what, in hindsight,
everything that happened up until the fall of this giant makes a lot.
Of sense. But to.
Understand this story,
we have to go back to 1993 that's year Kodak chose George Fisher,
the first outsider in the company,
the 117 year history to lead this multinational,
you were chosen to carry out an internal revolution.
Although we may find the timeframe surprising way back in 1993 Fisher,
who came from Motorola was chosen to focus on one thing.
The business of digital photography.
You.
See faced with the prospect that new digital technologies could wipe out Kodak's
business model.
The company devoted enormous resources to diversifying X activity four years.
As we have already mentioned, they bought up pharmaceutical companies,
clinical diagnosis companies and battery managers.
[Inaudible].
They even developed their very own nuclear reactor to carry out their research.
Yeah, yeah. A private nuclear reactor.
Check it out.
Black reveals had secrets nuclear reactor for 30 years and dependent.
Oh, this was something that Fisher considered a serious,
very serious mistake because it basically meant neglecting their main.
Business.
Arrived. We were not investing in the core business.
Think of the signal we sent to the core business teams.
When most of the strategies and decisions have been diverting resources to other
areas such as healthcare or consumer goods, George Fisher.
No sooner said than done in his first year at the helm of the company Fisher and
his new team sold virtually every non-photo business.
He used the resources he raised to do two things,
reduce the group's debts to almost zero and invest heavily in the core business
of photography.
I think there was a fear of the digital while I was coming here,
because I believe that the digital image and the core business of photography
have a symbiotic relationship, which is in fact exciting. George Fisher.
The idea behind this new equipment is that Kodak would be able to reproduce this
ecosystem in a digital environment. In other words, in the longterm,
although much later than the market fought,
the real ones would indeed disappear.
But Kodak understood that both the storage of the photographs and the printing
would more than compensate for this. And not only that,
they were also convinced that emerging countries like China would yield a lot.
And I mean a lot of money. And in fact, that's the path they took.
They invested hundreds and hundreds of millions of dollars into the Asian giant
to create not only digital camera factories,
but also to encourage the opening of nearly 7,000 development shops,
however things, well, they didn't go.
On the one hand.
Kodak had to face increasing competition in the field of film and photo
printing,
which affected the margins of the business that would sooner or later begin to
see it. Sales decline.
This meant a reduction in economies of scale and the need to cut production
capacity with all that. This entails layoffs, depreciation of assets,
damage to image reduction of retail outlets and therefore of opportunities for
cross-selling, et cetera, et cetera. Then on the other hand,
the company had to double down on its investment items in the new digital image
industry,
a world in which it's more than 100 years of experience with practically
useless.
So between 1993 and 2000 Kodak spent almost $9 billion on R
and D.
And finally.
The most important problem of all the digital ecosystem simply did not pack
what's worse.
The technological changes continued advancing until they reached the world.
We all know today,
a world in which digital cameras have practically disappeared because they're
now integrated into devices like mobile
To say that the changes came about at a much faster rate and Kodak's management
had anticipated. And of course, after divesting itself of radically,
all of the assets outside the world,
photography Kodak had concentrated all its efforts on this business and the
business model no longer worked.
In.
This way from 2001, everything started to fall apart. And finally in 2012,
the company went bankrupt. As you can see,
codex big problem was not so much the arrival of the digital camera,
but more that they put all of their eggs in one basket thinking they could
dominate technological change whilst Kodak's management thought about making
money from photo CDs or keeping their film real business going for quite some
time,
people started to share their photos digitally on networks like Facebook photo
log or to NT.
What would they pay Kodak.
For?
And that's how the success story came to an end until now when it's made the
headlines again.
The Corona virus.
I told you at the beginning of this video during the month of August, 2020,
Kodak has grabbed many headlines thanks to its spectacular rise in market prices
in late July.
Kodak is now a much smaller company and continues to do basically what it is
always. However, over the last few years,
it has tried to regain its shimmer with many different projects,
including a bit to launch its own crypto currency, Kodak coin,
something that also had an effect on the stock market, by the way.
9Th of January, 2018,
Kodak announces its own Kodak coin cryptocurrency.
And it shares soar by 125%. Shataka.
Well now in the midst of the coronavirus pandemic,
Kodak wants to rescue it's bet on the pharmaceutical business and it wants to do
so. Thanks to a loan of almost $800 million from the United States government to
manufacture pharmaceutical compounds with which to fight COVID 19. And that,
that was exactly what produced these spectacular reevaluation that the company
came to experience in just two days of stock market activity.
As we outlined at the beginning, however, at the time of preparing this video,
the loan is not yet secure and not all the details are yet known.
What we do know is that it has been a surprise that it is Kodak,
a company outside of the drug business that has taken on such a contract.
Kodak,
sheers plunge after $765 million us government loon hits hurdled
federal agency to pause funding deal after recent allegations of wrongdoing,
the financial times.
The question is will Kodak rise from the ashes. We cannot know,
but what we do know for sure is that these sudden market movements have caused
winners. Yes,
but also many people have also lost a lot of money in just a few days.
The volatility created many millionaires and destroyed fortunes.
It was a wild speculative move in which the market suddenly became very much
like a casino. And what do you want me to say?
We've prepared this video with value school.
So watch out for those jumps that can pulverize your savings going from $2 to
$60. Sounds great. But going from $60 to $8 is very painful.
So what do you think about the rise and fall of Kodak?
How do you think you could have avoided it?
Leave us your thoughts down here as always in the comments.
And if you find this video interesting,
don't forget to hit the like button take care and we'll see you next time.